oh
i was feeling so good oh my god
[Music]
hi i'm sam and i'm sepi and today we're
going to be labeling a map of south
america nope of latin america
i'm pretty bad at geography i've never
been a good maps person i'm bad at
geography in london i can't do a truth
map so this is gonna be fun i have
actually been to latin america i've been
to three countries which have been
mexico
oh i have been to mexico cuba and costa
rica i had to think about that i think i
know the big ones but it's the small
ones that i think are going to be a bit
confusing we have 21 countries and we
have five minutes on the clock
so here we go three two one go okay okay
okay so let's get usa up straight away
we know usa's there okay so mexico nice
pretty certain in that okay so obviously
mexico okay in brazil um okay i know
this is cooper okay i've been to cuba
and it's beautiful chile chile
i always remember because it kind of
looks like a little chilly
this is argentina yes yes correct and
then come on this is brazilian clearly
bristol bristol
yeah obviously bristol my very first
girlfriend ever was from uruguay
yeah i don't know how that one worked
out but uh
this one
um i think
this is ecuador
sure i don't know let's go okay so what
else do we have um ah okay okay
i know this one's costa rica and i know
panama is next door i know that to also
be true so that's good this is ecuador
oh oh okay that means peru must be right
under um this is this is um
through cuba yes yeah yeah cuba haiti's
one of these islands
and i'm imagining it's this okay
but i know this is puerto rico i know
that's puerto rico
so did you just do a little i did
love okay dominican republic's here
katie i know haiti's around there too
okay
we can put them next to each other okay
let's do it
okay
like what are these what's after costa
rica
cool okay um
okay these big ones what are these big
ones um oh my gosh um oh um
okay i think what's next to it
what is next
[Music]
i was thinking that too
all right look at that bolivia
this is bolivia oh okay we're gonna i'm
saying oh have we done everything i
don't know i don't know okay what's next
to colombia venezuela
yeah
honduras for this one
what is right below mexico i literally
don't know guacamole guacamole
10 seconds
10 seconds you guys
panama panama
well geography wasn't my best subject
and that just proved it i think we got
at least a 10 out of 21. so you got 19
out of 21. oh my god that's so good so
we completely forgot to even just put
nicaragua on there
do i get one wrong and it's the one we
missed yeah
stop stop it
how's that possible
[Music]
no
i think like you knew 50 percent of the
map and i needed to use them up so
together we like got it right
whereas like if i was alone i wouldn't
have done that well yeah so i'm so tough
honestly i'm just glad my sporting
knowledge from the world cup and the
olympics will come in handy wow
i actually can't believe we did that
yeah i'm really impressed and i think
now we deserve a triple american i
translate for you i'm the translator of
your book
why are all these people here i made
some changes
what have you done to my book
oh my lord i know it's hot in mexico